are you doing all right thank you great
t-shirt thank you
let me start by saying you were
fantastic in the movie have you I guess
my most of my big question of the day is
have you mailed a thank-you gift to the
casting director on the crown yet de
Nina yeah um I mean I don't know whether
I have have I given you a gift Nina I
don't think I have
I've sent up various emails over the
years thanking her for all the parts
she's given me but I see her quite often
actually I bump into her quite a lot so
I think probably every time I see her I
do that but I should probably buy her a
present
I mean maybe just a gift card you know
oh it's definitely done that right yeah
um
jumping into this character is
incredibly popular with so many people
what do you think it is about her that
resonates with so many people I think
she she feels out of sorts in the world
I think I think a lot of us do I don't
think a lot of us are told a lot of time
by society what is the definition of
success what means you belong what means
your normal what means that you fit in
and what means that you kind of make
sense and Elizabeth doesn't really fit
into any of those categories she doesn't
she's very complex she's very
complicated she seemingly unlikable in
lots of ways but and yet she's the
protagonist of this film and an
incredibly successful group of books oh
I think is that people identify with the
fact that she's she doesn't quite know
how to live in the world and that way
you got to I think this is your first
time doing this kind of action mm-hm and
I'm just curious what did you think it
was going to be like going in and what
was it actually like doing the action
making a film on the scale it's
difficult we I've never done an action
movie before and so when I read the
script to me there wasn't a lot of
action
and you know I suppose from my point of
view I had the two significant fights
but I never approach them like action
fights they were very little
choreographed and but they felt to me
like very kind of human fights that
Elizabeth was happening that they were
kind of clinging on to life and you know
fighting to the bitter end really it
required me to kind of get fit and kind
of be physically fit it couldn't to kind
of do the shoot as well because there
was so much kind of him physically
involved just day-to-day but yeah I mean
that was just a part the rest of it was
the kind of reacting stuff that I do the
rest of the time I'm curious how do you
typically like to work on set and was it
any different inhabiting this character
I don't really have any particular
approach on set on set I turn up and you
know and I'm working then go home well
I've spoken to some people to say like
they like absolute silence or they love
to blast music or they have like a thing
that helps them get into you can see
your face you're like no I'm very much
believed that you sort of make films
with other people I don't you know I I
do my work at home and I come ready and
I I love being on a film set to talk to
people and and you know I don't really
like keeping myself to myself in that
way but yeah I is my job to do my work
it's not I don't feel like I have to
take up you know anyone else's time by
me saying I need everyone to stop so I
can concentrate because that's not
really fair because everyone else is
trying to work at the same time what
they say yeah I just I like it being a
collaborative kind of relaxed
environment I'm a big fan of feta and
I'm just curious what if you could talk
a little bit about working with him
especially because he co-wrote he's
directing I thought of stopping her yeah
I think that fed a was the was was the
film in a way he no one else knew what
the film was apart from what was
happening in his head I suppose so
and he often didn't know what he wanted
or what he
until the day that you were shooting it
and he came to set and he would be
inspired by something or change
something or or he'd kind of have his
eyes opened in somewhere whether that
was by a crew member or number the cast
or the landscape that we were shooting
in or something like that so he's quite
free with the form that he's making but
he but the movie was definitely his baby
in that way you know we were all on
board with him I suppose and had faith
in him one moment making the movie one
of the things I really like is the way
he moves camera there's like a slowly
moving camera through scenes how much
are you looking at that you know how
much are you paying attention to where
the camera is and how much is it sort of
it's you don't even know where of it
when you're filming I mean you have to
be aware of the camera because the
camera is your friend in a way you know
you know knowing where it is and what
it's doing is is part of the job but you
know I I always just just keep on acting
and then hope that the camera at some
point picks it up yeah it's not I'm not
looking at the style when I'm when I'm
working really sure like I have to run
I'm looking at the clock run um yes
thank you so much for using I really
appreciate that
Oh Nathan
you